Venice is today an urban Disneyland a
place of remarkable beauty but little
economic dynamism beyond the tourist
trade the historic center of the city
welcomed 2.6 million tourists in 2014
but housed only 60,000 permanent
residents less than 1/2 of its
population in either the 1960s or the
1600s yet the city's beauty reflects
centuries of greatness for 600 years
Venice was among the most prosperous
places on the planet the city's great
wealth was produced primarily by trade
not conquest although it would be a
mistake to think of the line of Venice
as a tame beast Venetian commercial
success also rested on perhaps the most
effective urban government of the age
which could maintain internal order
deliver basic sanitary services and
fight wars with far mightier neighbors
in order to defend the city's vital
trade routes the history of Venice
begins in the chaotic centuries after
the fall of the Western Roman Empire the
islands of the venetian lagoon were
defensible space protected against
marauding Goths and Lombards even the
seaward approach to varus is hazardous
and the Venetians would later protect
themselves against naval assault by
removing the markers that show their own
ships the safe path to the city the
Venetian community was supposedly
started as a training outpost of nearby
Padua and for 21 in 528 cassiodorus
wrote of this settlements abundance of
fish and it's busy salt works
Venice's urban edge safety from attack
became even more important when the
lombards conquered the Byzantine empires
outpost on the Italian mainland the ex
arquette of Ravenna in 751 the islands
of the Venetian Lagoon remained free
from landlubbing Marauders and refugees
came to the last Italian outpost of the
Roman Empire the leaders of Venice the
doges the word is a variant of the Latin
ducks or Duke were originally seen as
representatives of the distant emperor
in Constantinople but by 803 Venice
declared itself independent enjoying its
position as a free port perfectly placed
between the northern Empire of
Charlemagne and the eastern empire of
Byzantium originally the islands
political core was on the barrier island
the Lido now famous for its Beach but in
810 when the Franks captured that outer
island
the Doge fled behind the barrier
to the area near the rialto bridge which
is protected by water from the shore and
protected by the Lido from the Adriatic
Sea
Venice is physical geography all those
canals delight millions of tourists but
initially the central core seems to have
been a set of marshy islands the current
city is essentially man-made held up by
wooden poles and connected by scores of
bridges Venice is long run success
reflected its extraordinary political
institutions probably the strongest in
the world
which were capable of harnessing
collective action for the common good
but also capable of stopping any one
Venetian from establishing a
dictatorship this commercial city was no
bastion of laissez faire capitalism
arguably Venice needed such a strong
state because it's very geography needed
to be transformed to be habitable safe
and functional as a port even the
earliest settlers of Venice seemed to
put their houses on stilts to protect
them for the water
cassiodorus describes how Venetian homes
lie like sea birds nests half on sea in
half on land the Doge and yellow
participate zo who led the defense
against the Frankish attack of 810 set
off a major building campaign on the
inner islands the Venetians built wooden
bridges to connect the low-lying islands
they reinforced banks with sand to
protect their settlement from the waves
and they drove vast numbers of poles
into the water to provide firm support
for their buildings Santa Maria della
salute a built in 1630 to thank the
Virgin from freeing the city from the
plague sits atop more than 1 million
wooden poles the city built to protect
herself from the water and it built to
enable itself to cross the waves the
Venetian Arsenal was a massive
industrial complex dedicated above all
to shipbuilding it was a public not a
private enterprise the state would build
the ships and then auction them off
groups of merchants would buy Natha
galleys but the right to use the
galleries for a year central public
production enabled the Arsenal to
operate on a grand scale and to reap the
benefits of mass production six
centuries before Henry Ford's cars were
made in Detroit the Arsenal was a public
enterprise but the nation government
operated neither like a modern democracy
that tries to balance the needs of all
its citizens nor like a medieval
monarchy fighting to advance the glory
and power of the sovereign and the
sovereign
housed the Venetian Republic was almost
like a commercial enterprise wrapped up
in the garments of statecraft
it was run by the lagoons leading
families who were themselves almost
entirely merchants and it embarked on
undertakings that would increase the
wealth of that trading aristocracy did
Venice's trading galleys need posts for
resupplying themselves along the
adriatic did venice his voracious
appetite for wood which was used both to
build the city and to build its galley
need for us then the most serene
Republic would need to conquer outposts
along the damnation coast of the
Adriatic Sea did Venice need a saintly
protector who had watched over the ships
and also tracked the pilgrimage trade
well then the dode would send merchants
to steal the body of st. mark that now
lies in the center of the city's
Cathedral the doges palace a tourist
highlight of the city provides a
physical tour the political
infrastructure that produced such a
model of corporate governance the palace
is not the mansion of a prince for
doshas were elected officials who
typically took office late in life
giving hope to us all but the
administrative hub of a mercantile
Empire the palace contains a glorious
Tintoretto portrait of notaries where
else but in Venice would you see such a
celebration of formal financial
transactions in the massive and
magnificently decorated chamber of the
Great Council all of the adult males of
the city's leading families would
assemble to pass laws and to elect the
powerful Council of 10 the chamber
contains portraits of all the city's
daughters except for Marin Valley whose
space is empty he tried to take down the
Republic and bear the palm alone but
unlike Julius Caesar he failed the
Venetian Republic smirk and how
defenders were much stronger than the
Senators who wanted to preserve the
older roman republic the rialto bridge
marks the center of the city's old
harbor galleys would come to the Grand
Canal and unload the riches of the East
Spice and silk gems and glass brought
from Egypt and Constantinople but some
of Venice's Byzantine relics were taken
by conquest
rather than earned through trade when
Venice sold its services to the soldiers
the Fourth Crusade it first demanded
military support help capturing the city
of Zara to provide another trading
outpost for the Republic the Pope
excommunicated Venice for turning a
crusade into an attack on a Christian
city the Republic regularly shrugged off
such display as a papal peak you
more importantly the Venetians and
Crusaders later repeated this trick by
capturing Constantinople itself the
horses of the basilica of san marco was
stolen from constantinople as ancient
Hippodrome Byzantium skilled glass
workers were brought back to Venice and
formed the nucleus of the city's
remarkable glass industry that persists
to this day supplying jewelry and
knickknacks for tourists from all over
the world
later scholarly refugees from
Constantinople would provide the text
for Aldus Manutius whose outine press
would turn Venice into Europe's printing
powerhouse trade in warfare were never
far apart during the Middle Ages Venice
fought bitter Wars with Genoa during the
14th century over access to the markets
of the east venice encouraged the
ottomans to snuff out Portuguese
explorers where the temerity to round
the tip of Africa and obtain direct
access to the spice markets of the East
venice played an important role in the
1571 Battle of Lepanto which stopped
Ottoman expansion in the Mediterranean
the Mediterranean Sea was the highway of
Venetian commerce and the Republic was
always willing to fight to ensure that
its galleys could cross the seas waters
as a Mediterranean power Venice steadily
lost importance as commerce became
global Atlantic powers like Holland and
England ultimately became more important
mercantile powers during the more
globalized 17th century Venice's
independence was snuffed out by Napoleon
in 1797 but by then the glory years of
the most serene Republic were long gone
yet Venice remains a place of
spectacular beauty built not by kings
but by extremely successful merchants it
is a city of Commerce but one that
reminds us that Commerce like successful
cities often rest on the strength of
strong political institutions
you